[Musique]
bonjour allen fera davantage à la une de
la presse aussi cette décision de la
russie de reconnaître l'indépendance des
régions séparatistes de l'est de
l'ukraine on va commencer par jeter un
coup d'oeil au quotidien russe tous les
membres du conseil de sécurité se sont
prononcés en faveur de l'indépendance de
donetsk et de lougansk d'après
commerçante cette annonce ouvre la voie
à une entrée des troupes russes dans les
territoires séparatistes du dombass qui
se trouve à l'est de l'ukraine l'a dit
hier poutine reconnaît de facto
l'indépendance des républiques
populaires autoproclamée en 2014 selon
un politologue si t'es pas vedomosti
autres quotidiens russes le but de la
manoeuvre du kremlin serait de jouer sur
les nerfs de washington et de ses alliés
et de les forcer à faire pression sur le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
pour qu'il respecte les accords de minsk
1 sur les territoires séparatistes
ukrainien quelle réaction précisément en
ukraine may le prix la presse
ukrainienne parcouru par courrier
international estime que la nourrice du
kremlin est la suite logique des
événements de ces derniers jours qui
avait déjà montré sans ambiguïté je cite
que la partie russe n'était pas disposé
à la désescalade le journal des
notamment affirme que les agents et les
marionnettes de la russie je cite
toujours reproduise en réalité le
scénario de la russie qui avait déjà été
appliquée avant la guerre de géorgie en
2008 avec de la même manière grossière
c'est à dire alors se livrant à des
provocations sur le front et en
organisant l'évacuation de la population
civile vers la russie
voilà c'était pour le casier et le ceti
la presse européenne ll est un peu plus
partagés on a une partie des quotidiens
semble effectivement prendre simplement
acte de l'annnonce du kremlin à l'image
du financial times qui rappelle
l'incrédulité exprimé ces derniers jours
à la fois par de nombreux diplomates et
dirigeants occidentaux face au briefing
pour le mois alarmistes des services de
renseignement américains
quid de la rencontre prévue ce jeudi
entre les chefs de la diplomatie
russe américaine à genève à sommet entre
poutine et joe biden at il encore la
moindre chance c'est peu probable de
voir le jour le journal suisse le temps
exprimant tout cas sa perplexité face au
jeu de pression de manipulation et de
propagande auquel se livre aussi bien
washington comme ce coup et alors pour
notre quotidien l'heure n'est plus aux
questions sur les intentions de vladimir
poutine peut-on encore éviter une guerre
en europe pour the guardian la question
est purement rhétorique puisque le
quotidien britannique affirme non
seulement que la russie avance vers une
action militaire n'est que cette
intervention sera majeur d'après le
quotidien britannique
cette action aura même était en germe
depuis 15 ans depuis que vladimir
poutine aurait déclaré sa guerre
personnelle contre l'occident dans son
discours à la conférence de munich de
2007 où le président russe dénonçait
déjà le nid latéral isme des états unis
le patron du kremlin est accusé pour le
moi de poursuivre l' escalade lanaudière
et en signant la fin du processus de
paix sous médiation franco allemande
selon le quotidien belge le soir
vladimir poutine accusée de torpiller
les efforts de paix par le quotidien
français le figaro pour qui la décision
damien de reconnaître l'indépendance des
territoires ddt ukrainien pro russe
résonne je cite comme une déclaration de
guerre même son cloche du côté du
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung le
quotidien allemand on voit lui aussi la
russie sur le chemin de la guerre
personne ne doit plus se faire
d'illusion sur qui dirige le kremlin et
les européens doivent tout faire en
saveurs de la dissuasion y compris
nucléaire assène le quotidien allemand
qui va t'arriver l'heure des sanctions
sévères de lieu contre la russie d'après
le new york times la réplique
occidentale dépendra de l'ampleur de la
taxe russe dont le journal dit ignorer
si elle prendra la forme d'une incursion
mineurs ou d'une glaire ou d'une guerre
éclair et massive de new yok times
damien qui estime que ce qui est en
train de se passer est certes la guerre
de poutine mais que les états unis
autant ont aussi leur part de
responsabilité
le journal met en cause notamment la
décision irréfléchie je cite des états
unis
d'élargir le temps après ou même malgré
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique et
au washington post où il va plus loin
trop loin peut être en tout cas il suit
la ligne une partie de washington selon
lui l'objectif de vladimir poutine
serait prendre le contrôle total de
l'udc elle selon le quotidien américain
qui envisage le scénario selon lequel la
russie parviendraient pas à atteindre
cet objectif
résumé la russie avec l'ukraine
deviendrait un animal stratégique
totalement différent la menace la plus
immédiate concernant selon ce scénario
les pays baltes une fois que la russie
aura achevé sa conquête de l'ukraine
cette question constituera une nouvelle
urgence prédit le quotidien américain
qui poursuit ce qui est pour l'instant
velay avait rappelé un scénario qui
relève de la fiction géopolitique en
relevant que les événements en ukraine
se produisent alors que la chine menace
de bouleverser l'équilibré en asie de
l'est avec peut-être une attaque contre
taïwan ce qui confrontera alors les
états unis à des défis stratégiques
simultané sur des théâtres éloigné un
scénario
catastrophe voilà il ya encore beaucoup
de peut-être ce qu'on va suivre